one way of assessing how emotionally
damaged we might be is to identify a
range of markers of emotional health and
imagine how we fare in relation to them
at least four central themes suggest
themselves firstly self-love self-love
is the quality that determines how much
we can be friends with ourselves and day
to day remain on our own side when we
meet a stranger who has things we don't
how quickly do we feel ourselves pitiful
and how long can we remain assured by
the decency of what we have and are when
another person frustrates or humiliates
us can we let the insult go able to
perceive the senseless malice beneath
the attack or we left a brooding and
devastated implicitly identifying with
the verdict of our enemies how much can
the disapproval or neglect of public
opinion be offset by the memory of the
steady attention of a few significant
people in the past in relationships do
we have enough self-love to leave an
abusive Union or are we so down on
ourselves that we carry an implicit
belief that harm is all we deserve in a
different vein how good are we at
apologizing to a lover for things that
may be our fault
how rigidly self-righteous do we need to
be can we dare to admit mistakes or does
an admission of guilt or error bring us
too close to our background sense of
nullity in the bedroom
how clean and natural or alternatively
disgusting and sinful to our desires
feel might they be a little odd but not
for that matter bad or dark since they
emanate from within us and we are not
wretches at work do we have a reasonable
well grounded sense of our worth and so
feel able to ask for and properly expect
to get the rewards with jus can we
resist the need to please others
indiscriminately are we sufficiently
aware of our genuine contribution to say
sometimes no Kanda Kanda determines the
extent to which difficult ideas and
troubling facts can be consciously
admitted into the mind soberly explore
and accepted without denial how much can
we admit to ourselves about who we are
even if or especially when the matter is
not especially pleasant how much do we
need to insist on our own normality and
wholehearted sanity can we explore our
own minds and look into their darker and
more troubled corners without flinching
overly can we admit to folly Envy
sadness and confusion around others how
ready are we to learn do we need always
take a criticism of one part of us as an
attack on everything about us how ready
are we to listen when valuable lessons
come in painful guises communication can
we patiently and reasonably put our
disappointments into words that more or
less enable others to see our point or
do we internalize pain acted out
symbolically or discharged it with
counterproductive rage when other people
upset us do we feel we have the right to
communicate or must we slam doors and
retreat into sulks when the desired
response isn't forthcoming do we ask
others to guess what we've been too
angrily panicked to spell out or can we
have a plausible second go and take
seriously the thought that others are
not merely being nasty in
misunderstanding us do we have the inner
resources to teach rather than insist
trust how risky is the world how readily
might we survive a challenge in the form
of a speech a romantic rejection about a
financial trouble a journey to another
country or a common cold how close are
we at anytime to catastrophe what
material are we made of will new
acquaintances like or wound us if we're
a touch assertive will they take it or
collapse will unfamiliar situations end
in a debacle around love how tightly do
we need to cling if they're distant for
a while will they return how controlling
do we need to be can we approach an
interesting-looking stranger or move on
from an unsatisfying person do we
overall feel the world to be wide safe
and reasonable enough for us to have a
legitimate shot at a measure of can
or must we settle resentfully for
inauthenticity and misunderstanding it
isn't our fault or in a sense anyone
else's that many of these questions are
so hard to answer in a positive
direction but by entertaining them we
are at least starting to know what kind
of shape our psychological wounds have
and so what kind of bandages might be
most necessary if you liked this film
please subscribe to our Channel and
click the bell icon to turn on
notifications if you want to learn more
about self-knowledge follow the link on
your screen now to see our range of
books games and gifts all about
self-knowledge